B-stall. A very good descent manoeuvre. Sadly it's fallen a bit into disrepute.
B-stall. We pull all the B-risers and so squash the wing together via the B riser group.
We stall the wing — so it goes from forward flight into the stall and then descends in the so-called deep stall.
But with the wing still open across its full span, just compressed via the B riser group.
We get roughly 7 metres per second sink rate, which is pretty good.
And the great thing about the B-stall is that you have practically no physical strain.
It's a bit demanding at the start, but holding it afterwards actually goes quite well.
But you have no physical strain, so you can also do it nicely over a longer period.
Steep spiral — you know it from me, no issue.
It's not suitable for losing altitude over a longer period.
Especially not with the wings we have today.
There you simply have too much physical load.
Anyone who fancies it as an acro pilot can do that of course, but it's not an effective manoeuvre to use whenever you need to lose altitude.
B-stall: we just take the brake loosely at the loop in the hand.
Now, so that the B-risers don't slip out unintentionally, we go with our fingers spread between the B-lines, above the line-locks.
And grip them like this.
Symmetrically, nicely above the line-locks.
And that way the B-risers can't slip out of our grip unintentionally.
Now what's important: we simply do a slow but powerful pull-up on them.
And we hold this for at least four to five seconds.
Only on my command — hands up — do the hands go up for the exit.
And now I'll show you why the hands have to go all the way up.
If from this position we simply
let the B-risers shoot up, we'd perhaps additionally end up on the brake.
That would be problematic, because now we're letting the B-stall release.
The wing wants to fly forward, but is still in deep stall for a moment.
And if I then go on the brake, I'm actually telling it, bang, hey, transition into backward flight.
And that's why we absolutely don't want to let the risers snap up, but really actively guide them upwards.
Then we nicely let the wing come out of the B-stall into forward flight.
On the entry we leave the B-risers — that's why this comb grip is so important —
also don't let them snap up again when we're surging forward,
because then the wing would, from that position, start flying again straight away and could accelerate quite well
and possibly even accelerate too hard.
That's why it's important to hold the B-stall, or the B-risers, for at least three to four seconds,
at least three to four seconds, working with the risers.
At least three to four seconds, working with the risers.
And then keep them down.
So pull them down, keep them down, so we can swing back under the wing again.
And only then, once we've swung back under, do the hands go up for the exit.